we're going to dive straight in with our
main story this week which concerns
afghanistan a country that's blessed the
world with innumerable treasures from
embroidery to traditional pashto and
persian poetry to the afghan hound
undoubtedly the real housewife of show
dogs
she's a messy [ __ ] and she lives for
drama
this week march mark the one year
anniversary of our withdrawal from
afghanistan which you may remember
was complete mayhem
they were scenes marked by chaos and
desperation
hundreds of afghan citizens running
alongside a departing usc 17. now nearly
a year after the u.s withdrawal the
indelible images remain a u.s marine
lifting a baby over a barbed wire topped
wall at kabul's airport and this photo
taken by technical sergeant justin
triola how many people do you think are
on your job
[Music]
800 people on your jet
holy cow
yep i think everyone knew the u.s
occupation was going to end badly but
it's still shocking just how bad it was
in terms of things not going the way
that you thought our exit was the
foreign policy equivalent of putting a
cake in the oven and then 40 minutes
later taking out a live rat dressed as
hitler it's not just a fuck-up it's a
mind-blowing fuck-up that'll take years
to fully comprehend
everything happened so fast apparently
even the taliban was surprised at how
quickly the afghan government fell and a
pretty decent way of knowing if the us
did a good job at something is by asking
the question was whatever we did a fun
surprise for the taliban
within a matter of days the afghan
government fell and the taliban took
over and many top u.s military officials
have struggled since then to put into
words just how badly they miscalculated
with general mark milley putting it like
this
all the intel assessments all of us got
that wrong there's no question about it
uh that was a swing and a miss on the
intel assessment of 11 days in august
there's nobody that called that yeah
that's about right swinging a miss
describes roughly 40 percent of the us
government's history the breakdown of
stuff we've done goes something like
this forty percent swing and a miss
twenty percent beefed it fifty percent
whoops fifty percent whoops parentheses
murders and ten percent delivered most
but not all of the mail
and look
there is a lot to criticize about the
way we left afghanistan including the
fact that while we managed to get
roughly 80 000 afghans many of whom had
worked with the u.s to america since the
withdrawal the number who remain in
danger because of their association with
the us mission can be counted in the
hundreds of thousands so criticism of
what happened is completely justified
though maybe not from the guy whose
administration signed the deal to leave
in the first place
bagram is this great air base that was
built many years ago at a cost of
billions and billions and we left in one
night everybody was gone they left the
lights on think of it the lights were
all left on the dogs were left behind by
the way for those people that like dogs
but we left and they don't like dogs you
know that
they don't like dogs
they don't like them at all
what
honestly it has been a while since we've
heard trump's voice on this show and i
somehow forgot just how bizarrely
incoherent he is
it's truly extraordinary to see his
brain function like a crow spotting a
crumpled up can because he's flying he's
flying he's flying and then wall nearly
hold on is that what i think it is shiny
garbage nose dive also comments about
people not liking dogs are a little odd
coming from a man who every time he
holds one seems to make the dog want to
die
but we're we're not actually going to
talk about the withdrawal from
afghanistan tonight instead we're going
to focus on everything that's happened
since because while afghanistan has
faded as a topic of discussion in this
country it really shouldn't because it's
in dire crisis right now and i will
admit this is a grim topic but it's also
an important one because things are
going worse in afghanistan than you may
know for reasons that have even more to
do with our decisions than you might
think so tonight let's check in on
afghanistan and let's start with the
fact that as i mentioned earlier the
taliban is now in charge and in the
early days of their takeover they tried
to convey a slightly softer image to
journalists through carefree photo ops
like this one where taliban members
visited a fairground in kabul
or this one where they took a trip to
the zoo and really spelled out the
message that they wanted the world to
hear
we want to show everyone that under
islamic rule and security everything is
enjoyable and everyone can live in their
own country the way they want
yeah sure yeah because that's what you
associate the taliban with freedom for
everyone to live their best life
also for what it's worth i don't think
losing the right to drive bumper cars or
go to the zoo was at the top of anyone's
list of concerns when the taliban took
over it's akin to the pope saying don't
worry everyone catholics are still
allowed to use pogo sticks okay great
but to be honest that's not the main
issue people have with the catholic
church right now
and while the taliban is not actually a
monolith different regional leaders rule
with different degrees of severity i do
still feel comfortable saying
everything's very much not enjoyable for
everyone in afghanistan right now for
starters they've been brutal reprisals
against u.s allies and former afghan
government employees nearly 500 of whom
were killed or forcibly disappeared
during the taliban's first six months in
power and on a much bigger level the
taliban's taken an absolute sledgehammer
to women's rights for all the many
legitimate criticisms of america's
occupation women did make huge gains
there in 2001 there were few if any
girls in school and by 2020 girls made
up roughly 40 percent of all students
that same year afghanistan's parliament
had a higher percentage of women than
the u.s congress did but now they've
essentially gone back to zero but much
more than that taliban decrees have
tried to control nearly every aspect of
women's lives ordering that they
shouldn't leave their homes unless
necessary and that only women who can't
be replaced by men will be allowed to
keep working in fact one of the only
areas women can work is in health care
because there are some situations where
men aren't allowed to treat women as
patients this midwife for example is
still working in a hospital but she is
furious about what she sees happening to
her country
the taliban cannot ban me from working
in the hospital because they know
do not meddle in women's rights to
education and employment
otherwise they are amputating one arm
from the body of society our societies
are made of two pillars a pillar of men
and another pillar of women
how can you run your life one-sided yeah
of course you can't run a society on a
pillar of just men i mean we've tried
for thousands of years we have tried but
look where it's got us we have a global
pandemic the planet is on fire the
babysitter's club is cancelled despite
unparalleled critical success and the
world's richest man is a ventriloquist
dummy from hell let's
maybe lean on that one pillar a little
bit less
and things are getting worse because in
march the taliban went back on a promise
that they made after they took over and
announced the girls would be prevented
from receiving a secondary school
education in most of the country now
that decision drew widespread
condemnation in afghanistan including
from many taliban members but the
leadership pushed back claiming that
it's just temporary and arguing among
other things that they simply needed
more time to decide on a school uniform
for teenage girls which is clearly total
[ __ ]
besides for an organization so concerned
with virtue and purity taking months to
brainstorm a schoolgirl uniform you like
is objectively the single pervious thing
you can do
so women in particular have lost a great
deal in the last year but on top of that
the whole country is facing a cascading
series of humanitarian crises the un has
estimated that as much as 97
of the population is at risk of sinking
below the poverty line and part of that
is due to a series of natural disasters
from an ongoing severe drought that's
hit around 80 of the country devastating
food production to a massive earthquake
in june and flooding just this month but
that's been exacerbated by the fact that
this is all falling on a brand new
taliban government that is in no way
equipped to take it on
the taliban now need to shift from being
a jihadist insurgency to a ruling
group for 20 years you've built an
organization that was designed to fight
and you motivated people to engage in
suicide bombings they don't turn into
people who are government officials
overnight yeah of course not a militant
insurgency group is pretty low on the
list of people that you want leading a
government right around the hells angels
the manson family and ron desantis
and to be a million percent clear i am
not suggesting that the u.s occupation
was a perfect magic wonderland it was
awful in its own ways not least having
to live under the specter of hellfire
being rained down from flying unmanned
death machines every day our continued
presence there was untenable but the
exact circumstances of our departure
have to a significant degree made things
substantially worse because we've made a
series of decisions some of them
understandable that have had huge
ramifications for the afghan people and
let's start with the taliban government
itself when it took over many of its
members were already sanctioned by the
us because we list the taliban as a
specially designated terrorist group so
suddenly those pre-existing sanctions
apply to at least part of the taliban
government take siradhin haqqani the
state department currently has a 10
million reward out for information
leading to his arrest but you should
know
he's the current acting interior
minister there so guess what state
department i found him
can you mail me by 10 million dollars
now please don't worry i spend my money
very wisely
so individuals in the taliban government
are sanctioned which effectively means
the whole government is making it nearly
impossible for banks businesses and
charities to operate there which is a
massive problem especially because
75
of the former afghan government's budget
came from foreign aid and grants
75
that was the money that among other
things paid the salaries for vital
government services like teachers and
public sector employees and all that aid
disappeared almost immediately as one
expert has said no country in the world
could withstand a sharp cut off of that
aid and it's affected everything in
health care for instance the world bank
and other organizations immediately
froze 600 million dollars in aid which
left doctors in a very difficult
position
this state hospital in the heart of
kabul has not received funding since the
taliban takeover
we don't have any medicine here
we had antibiotics painkillers and
vitamins here but it's empty now what's
your budget now in in total for the
department for the total departments
we didn't have just only for our
salary we have budget for uh other
item we didn't have any budget so you
mean your budget is zero
budget is zero yeah yeah
zero it is hard to imagine how a
hospital can even function with a budget
of zero unless every exam room is just a
paper bag and a sign that says yell what
hurts into this bag then leave
and it gets even worse because the us
also froze afghanistan's central bank
assets held in america amounted to
around seven billion dollars now that is
money typically used to do things like
keep the currency stable finance imports
and provide money to the banking system
the us froze those assets to prevent the
taliban from accessing them but that
also kneecaps the country's entire
banking system especially as afghanistan
doesn't have the ability to print its
own currency all of this led to a
literal cash shortage where even afghans
who do have money in the bank can't
access it so they've been massive lines
and weights just to get money out at
some banks withdrawing cash has
reportedly taken three days or more and
that has brought the country to an
unusual state of affairs
this is a unique humanitarian crisis
this is a situation where food is
technically available but there isn't
enough liquidity in the economy and
enough availability of paper currency to
purchase food food which is available
right and that is awful food but no
money to buy it with it's like a lyric
from alanis morrissette's ironic in that
it's fundamentally not ironic at all and
i'm sure dave coulier is still somehow
to blame
things are very grim in afghanistan its
population is young nearly half are
under the age of 15 and unicef has
warned that over a million severely
malnourished children will be at risk of
death without emergency treatment this
year and because many afghans have
nowhere to turn for food or for money
families have been forced to make some
harrowing choices
forty-year-old gulam hazrat sold his
kidney for around two thousand three
hundred dollars
[Music]
it's true he sold his kidney to feed his
kids
a desperate decision that you can make
precisely once
that's actually an increasingly common
decision in afghanistan and it's not
just that families are also selling some
of their children so that they can feed
the others which is just unimaginably
heartbreaking so clearly the people of
afghanistan are in dire need of help and
the current president has at times been
alarmingly blithe about the situation
there
do i feel badly
what's happening to
we as a consequence of the incompetence
of the taliban
yes i do
but i feel badly also about the fistulas
that are taking place in eastern congo
i feel badly about a whole range of
things around the world that we can't
solve every problem okay first i hate to
be a marion the librarian but you don't
feel badly you feel bad
feel is a linking verb and you're
modifying it incorrectly marion out
but
for a second
it's pretty disheartening to see our
official foreign policy boil down to
sorry champ can't win them all
especially when the us is so directly
responsible for so many problems in
afghanistan
and in eastern congo by the way but that
is a different story
now the obama administration will point
out that it's begun issuing sanctions
exemptions to allow the free flow of
some humanitarian aid and it sent
hundreds of millions in relief to
afghanistan more than any other country
which is absolutely true and it's also
true that they've done that in the face
of stiff opposition from some on the
right who argue in pretty strong terms
against any kind of assistance and for
one particular reason
obviously humanitarian suffering all
over this planet right uh i i don't i'm
not in favor of giving money that i'm
pretty confident we end up in the hands
of the taliban we should not give them
one red ascent until such time as we can
demonstrate that they have actually done
what they said they would do which is to
separate themselves from terror look
mike pompeo and deep fake blake shelton
here are clearly
[ __ ] although i will say for even
non-assholes it is natural to be
concerned about the prospect of usaid
money going to the taliban but a couple
of things you should know for years now
charities have been able to find ways to
work with through or around the taliban
to help ordinary afghan citizens they
had to do that because even when the us
was there the taliban effectively still
controlled large parts of the country
and for people at some of those groups
like the afghanistan director at the
international rescue committee the fact
that they are financially constrained
from helping people now is pretty
frustrating
i think a lot of people will say well i
don't we don't want to see aid go to
afghanistan because we don't want to
give money to the taliban that's an
extremist group
so you want to make 38 million people
suffer because of a few thousand
i that that math doesn't work for me
right
that math doesn't work for me either and
that is saying something because look at
me
i look like math in human form
i look like a pokemon whose final
evolution is a graphing calculator i
look like an algebra textbook left me on
the doorstep of an orphanage as a baby i
look like what matt damon's character in
goodwill hunting should have looked like
so when i say that math doesn't work you
better [ __ ] believe me
so there is a strong case to be made for
finding ways to get humanitarian aid to
afghanistan but that is not all it needs
in the long term no amount of emergency
relief can stand in for health care and
education system or a functioning
economy as one report said humanitarian
efforts are bandages not cures you can't
just keep applying them forever and
right now there are some worrying signs
of donor fatigue with contributions from
the international community drying up
even as nearly 20 million people that's
almost half afghanistan's population are
experiencing high and critical levels of
food insecurity so a more sustainable
way to help them is through development
aid building long-term solutions like
investing in health care and education
salaries or helping build infrastructure
through investments in irrigation and
water management in areas affected by
the drought but the tricky thing with
that is
that really does require some form of
engagement with the taliban now there
are mechanisms to try and ensure that
they don't end up benefiting financially
but admittedly none of them are perfect
and the idea of the taliban getting one
red cent
is obviously hard to swallow especially
because despite the taliban's new
outward-facing live laugh love vibe
they've continued to remind us how
terrible they are not only with their
heinous treatment of women but also with
the recent confirmation that they were
harboring the leader of al-qaeda in a
safe house
but withholding all forms of aid until
the taliban either give in or collapse
just is not a viable strategy because
for one thing who knows how long that
will take if ever and for another while
you're waiting potentially millions will
starve just listen to that midwife from
earlier who is no fan of the taliban
explain what she thinks of that logic
your sanctions on the taliban will kill
us faster than the violation of our
rights by the taliban
a girl dies from hunger and a mother
either sells her daughter because of
hunger or from pressure to marry her by
force
the issue of their education and
literacy is meaningless when you're
dying from hunger
yeah
she's right
there's no two ways around it this is a
crisis at the most fundamental level and
thankfully there have been some small
steps in the right direction recently
the u.s is working on a proposal to
release some of the billions of dollars
of frozen money into a trust fund that
the taliban themselves can't access
which could still help inject some cash
and stability into the country's
financial system if it happens also the
un and the world bank both have
initiatives in the works to try and
bridge the gap between emergency
humanitarian assistance and longer-term
development aid as long as they're able
to get adequate funding and for the
final time i do get the broad worries
about how sending money to afghanistan
might inadvertently help the taliban but
i'd argue the key question here isn't
just what happens if we send afghanistan
money and aid
it's what happens if we don't
and we know the answer to that millions
of innocent afghans will suffer and die
under a government they did not choose
the reality is there is no one simple
solution here that is without risks but
38 million people's lives are at stake
and doing nothing would be yet another
colossal if i may borrow a military
intelligence term here swing and amiss
you